one up here black Superman what's
happening you look amazing let me say a
match I swear this was really that's
your kryptonite what exactly the he
weighs that he was your kryptonite you
know he's gonna say that he's he's head
is bigger than mine on the posters I
love it
you do look fantastic marriage does you
well Oh does it looks good on you okay
that compliment you like it that way so
how about this shutting down Hollywood
Boulevard dueling red carpets is that's
what it's come to now between Dwayne and
J's and they get him be together
I know listen I think I didn't see them
coming but I heard they came in with
style I opted for the diss you know the
old fashioned know the two guys yeah you
know it's real it was real fun just
working with them you know like both of
them at the top of their game in terms
of you know like being action heroes and
I haven't made a movie like that with
them so it was amazing for me it was a
great experience through cops and
Turkish or we've got unfinished business
sure sister took something from me a
virus
we could wipe out half the population
and I want it back
word on the street is your villain is so
damn good being bad I don't know I mean
you know I put the work in I had a
really great character my character is
you know part man part machine I had an
opportunity to sort of create some day
but you know we do know I'm gonna call
you out you might play bad here but
you're all good we heard about you
rushing off stage to help a woman in the
audience of your play that was
apparently having a seizure what
happened actually I wasn't on stage I
was in the audience and she was very
close to me and she fell and and I had a
seizure had a few seizures actually and
it just felt right to stay with her you
know she was with her friend her friend
was you know a little emotional so we
just stay by her and try to help her out
you know and then the paramedics came in
and took care of her it was
heartbreaking though you know when you
see someone so close just like and I
wasn't sure what to do I just you know
held her hand and survived well that
meant more than anything I'm sure you DJ
the Royal Wedding yes was there any
Beyonce on the plate
there's always Beyonce the famous you
already know that no yeah the playlist
everyone's talking about the playlist
like I let the cat out of the bag didn't
I okay have you met Archie no no yeah
yeah he's cute congratulations to them
did you bring the whole family tonight
yeah my daughter's hair she looks
amazing
yeah everyone's doing that thing so it's
a family affair it is a family affair
by eg love you guys
[Applause]
[Music]